[Music]
you're with us on Al Jazeera we're just
cutting into the break to remind you of
the breaking news that we've had just in
the past half hour President of Russia
Vladimir Putin expressing his
condolences over the death of Russia's
most powerful Mercer University that's
you have any pregosian he is understood
to have been killed in a plane crash he
was lifted amongst 10 people on a jet
that came down north of Moscow and this
is the first official confirmation that
we've had from the Kremlin that Evgeni
pragosian has died or was died was
killed on that plane a Ukraine's
president uh Vladimir zielinski he
meanwhile has said that Kiev had nothing
to do with the plane crash in which
pagosian died he told journalists that
everyone is aware who is involved
Vladimir Putin sayings still waiting to
see the results of an investigation into
that crash let's go to Daniel Hawkins he
joins us live now from Moscow very
interesting Daniel that only some 24
hours later after that crash do we hear
from Vladimir Putin and the way he talks
about it is in a very sort of
understated way it almost as an aside in
a meeting with another official
yeah indeed it's um almost as if the
Kremlin wanted to uh minimize public
attention when it came to this this
aircraft crash because death uh this
incident the last 24 hours here uh in
Russia the media has been focused on
other news stories most know through the
brics uh somewhere in South Africa where
uh Vladimir Putin and Sergey lavrov
Russia's foreign minister made speeches
that's been the focus of media attention
very little time very little air time
devoted uh to the crash and the coverage
that was there was pretty much factual
very little speculation or analysis of
what exactly happened
um it did take a while as I say for this
confirmation to come through it's been
uh pretty much 24 hours since this crash
happened and the Russian civil aviation
Authority was very quick to release the
passenger list from this private
aircraft that in itself was quite an
unusual move of course with usual
civilian aircraft with aircraft
companies the passenger lists are San to
the aviation Authority automatically
you know when it comes to private
flights that is very different so many
were surprised that that list was
publicized and leaked to the media uh so
quickly
um we have been waiting for this
confirmation as I say because up until
now with the media reporting this as
progression was believed to have died he
was in the passenger lists according to
the investigators of course the bodies
the ten bodies recovered from this site
were in such a condition that
post-mortems would require some sort of
DNA analysis to identify them their
bodies were badly burnt due to the fire
and explosion alleged explosion on the
aircraft uh seemingly that has
officially now happened and yes indeed
Vladimir Putin
hailing pre-gaussians achievements
really in this meeting with uh Dennis
pushilin who's the head of the Donetsk
Republic saying that he knew him all the
way from the 90s that he was a talented
individual a talented businessman that
had dealings in Russia and abroad most
notably in Africa
even confirming that according to him
just yesterday or the day before he'd
returned from the African continent
which fits in of course with that video
that progression released saying that
wagon was continuing to as he said quote
serve Russian interests make Russia
Great and help free Africans from the
West uh filmed in an unidentified
African country Vladimir Putin also
saying that this investigation into the
crash would be completed would go until
the very end until those responsible
would be identified and of course
sending condolences to the bragosians
family also though saying that he was a
complex man who made serious mistakes no
doubt reference of course to the Mutiny
which progression LED uh just about two
months and a day to the day since that
took place back in June so as I say 24
hours after that radio Silence from
Russian officials this confirmation has
come from the Russian president that
progression has indeed died in that
accident and the investigation is
ongoing and we will wait for further
comment of course from any preliminary
results brought To Us by Russia's
investigative committee what have you
heard so far Daniel from that
investigation
while Russian media are saying there is
still an open mind as to what exactly
could have caused this uh accident and
the initial case that the investigators
opened wasn't a case of uh terrorism or
or murder it was a case opened into
Aviation safety breaches almost they uh
a criminal case but not something that
was intentional since then the Russian
media has reported more and more the
investigations gained traction and now
the theory of some sort of explosion on
board
um is the theory they're predominantly
looking at this is not something that's
uh you know been confirmed Through
official sources but has gained Traction
in the media as the day has gone on that
there was some sort of explosion
potentially uh in the uh carriage and
the undercarriage of the aircraft which
caused it to disintegrate partially at
least in mid-air and that's backed up by
what we officially know because
investigators have spread uh their
search for parts and for the black boxes
for the cockpit voice recorders to an
area of four kilometers that's quite a
large area
indeed part of the fuselage was
discovered three and a half kilometers
from the crash site that was cordoned
off by investigators we've seen images
in uh reported by the media of police
blocking off the road leading to that
crash site so media have had very
difficult time getting close to the area
due to that investigation so that is the
primary focus they're looking at and
also focus of course on who had access
to the aircraft before it took off on
its last flight trying to get in touch
with the owner of the company that the
aircraft was registered to trying to see
who could have been in that vicinity
interviewing Witnesses this is going to
be a long investigation as is any
investigation into an aircraft crash
made Difficult by the circumstances
um of the plane the way it was brought
down but as I say that explosion on
board reported by the Russian media
appears to be the primary Theory being
looked at by investigators yet still
maintaining an open mind into other
potential causes of course as well one
wonders Daniel weather now Vladimir
Putin has spoken about it and as you say
appears to have given official
confirmation of yevgeny progojian's
deaths on 24 hours ago in that jet crash
whether the Russian media will devote
more time to it because the it has been
relatively quiet today hasn't it even
whilst this has been top story in
headlines around the world
yeah the contrast couldn't be more
clearer as you rightly say this story
has sent shockwaves through the media
landscape the landscape across the world
the Russian media
this morning where I was across the
story some of the websites hadn't
updated the story since uh since last
night and it's very much fallen down the
pecking order and behind that brick
Summit behind even stories of national
even Regional or city-wide significance
it's almost as if the media had trouble
finding an angle going with what to say
here so the Russian media has been
reporting so far on this very factually
reporting on what they know uh what
happened for sure in terms of uh sort of
that they know in terms of where their
craft came down and the ongoing
investigation has been very little
analysis or speculation on what's gone
on although some officials like Sergey
moronov the chairman of the uh just
Russia party in Parliament has implied
there could be some Ukrainian Trace uh
behind this and again Sergey moronov is
a a politician he's not a uh a member of
the United Russia party he's not an
official in Putin's government that's
also what some analysts have pointed at
saying that uh what how could this have
benefited Putin pragosan was out of the
public Limelight maintaining a very low
profile for two months or low he was
spotted at the Saint Petersburg Forum
meeting African dignitaries he released
the video from Belarus recruiting Wagner
Fighters and released the video just a
few days ago as I say from Africa but
many say this man was no longer a threat
to Wagner was disarmed had handed over
its heavy Weaponry to the Russian mod to
the Russian security Services who could
have benefited from this so again very
little speculation from the Russian
media perhaps now this is confirmed
um that uh this this precaution has died
we could see more information seeping
through now uh on the Russian media
landscape yeah just interested to get an
idea as to how people the people have
reacted in Russia because of course
there are a lot of Wagner supporters and
indeed many members of the Wagner
mercenary group were great supporters of
Afghani pagosian
well there's no doubt your precaution
had a huge uh support uh affection and
respect among the Wagner Fighters
um that's the Testament that we've seen
uh the footage coming out of Saint
Petersburg the Wagner office where
people have been coming since last night
to lay flowers and wreaths and candles
in memory of progression one Wagner
fighter filmed falling to his knees
crying uncontrollably
um uh in front of a portrait of
progressions so there's there's no doubt
that he uh commanded great respect among
his fighters in Russia itself in terms
of the population he was certainly a
very controversial very divisive figure
Al Jazeera spoke to people on the
streets earlier some of whom had said
this man uh committed an lack of treason
he was a traitor he was a dangerous man
who brought the country to its most
serious political crisis in 30 years at
a time of conflict others though very
much viewed him as a man who spoke truth
to power who said things that needed to
be said truth that needed to be spoken
that was absent from the Russian
political discourse and was very
critical
of the Russian top brass the Russian
high command accusing them very publicly
and very aggressively of incompetence
and uh and Corruption again things that
most people would not would not be
saying in Russian public discourse this
was a very unusual anomalous
um thing to happen and for that reason
many people did view precaution with an
element of affection
um he also almost became a um a
meme-like character here on the Russian
internet with people uh quoting his
famous expletive Laden videos and his
accusations at defense minister Sergey
shogu and the head of general staff
Genie grasimov so again a controversial
a divisive figure here in Russia but
judging from the response we've seen uh
online and the people bringing flowers
to the Wagner PMC office certainly among
certain segments of the Russian
population he did command a degree of
affection and understanding at the very
minimum okay Daniel Hawkins for the
moment will leave it there thanks very
much brings all the very latest lines
from Moscow